what's going on reject nation greg and
john here today we are going to watch
the trailer for hawkeye about damn time
that jeremy renner got his own show i'm
hearing that this particular series is
most likely going to be inspired from
the matt fraction run which is regarded
as like the best hawkeye comic series
i'm very much excited to see what's in
store today thank you jeremy renner for
letting everyone know that the treasure
was coming out today it's always nice to
have a little bit of a heads up of
course we're going to be covering this
show on the channel full length watch
along it's really single with the
timecode for the show be at our patreon
page we cover a whole bunch of shows
over there as well such as marvel's what
if and you know a whole bunch of things
all right anyway if you enjoy reaction
please go ahead and hit that like button
let's swing on in action people see
what's going on with clint barton and
kate bishop
[Music]
this is the first christmas we've had
together for years
i love you guys
[Music]
[Music]
hearing aids in
when i wore this suit
i made a whole lot of enemies
i should be back in a day or two
oh nice
cool
there's a track suit dracula's
oh
vera farmer
lucky the dog
i think that was just high echo
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
awesome yeah that looks great very fun
it looks very fun yeah
real shane black vibes all throughout
that trailer with the banter the
christmas themes throughout the action
the action too yeah feels like a buddy
cop dynamic yeah absolutely absolutely
they're gonna be on odds at first but
then they're gonna be totally
synchronized by the end you see plenty
in this trailer all throughout you're
looking at the tracksuit draculas
they're the main people who are you know
like the ones in the tracksuit the red
outfits here at one point i do think you
see echo there were leaked photos of her
a while ago echo is a character who's a
native american deaf she is able to
mimic slash echo people's movements and
its exciting debut for her to be in here
i think she's going to be getting her
own disney plus series as well if i'm
not mistaken so it's going to be cool to
get like an introduction of her here in
the series transition into her own solo
series as well but for the most part
yeah i mean i was expecting a little bit
more of a grittier tone perhaps i think
it'll still probably preserve some of
that grit this is just the first trailer
the teaser trailer which is having that
christmas vibe and that's why i was
thinking so much of shane black the
buddy cop dynamic that you see between
the two of them how one is like an older
disgruntled you know a little bit grumpy
guy who's working with
the young protege i think their
chemistry looks really great together
i'm excited to see how the handoff of
the torch goes because i feel like clint
barton has been trying to retire for the
longest time in the mcu and something
keeps pulling him back in having to deal
with the sins of his past to a certain
extent the way she reacted to him was
very interesting to me when she was like
you're hawkeye because it that could be
you know sort of borrowing elements from
the comics she thought like hawkeye was
dead so she's taking up the mantle it
gets to a point where you know like when
hawkeye does show up like who's the
person pretending to be me on the
streets and then she's like oh my god
you're actually alive you got to train
me and then she has to earn her way
there plus it has like that spy dynamic
so there's so much going on in this
trailer that i'm really uh enjoying and
i left plenty for john to talk about
[Laughter]
generous of you no i love the tone of
this and i think that's a really nice
way to throw us a curveball because
hawkeye i mean i feel like if you'd gone
with a more serious more gritty toned
trailer it might not be as unique and i
feel like for the timing that they want
this to come out and the kind of
show like i don't know like it's it's
all about seeing what they have in store
but that shane black vibe does make me
think like maybe this will be a really
great sort of send-off for hawkeye in
terms of being you know like the mantle
of the character passing it off too k
bishop and everything but also keeping
it yeah like a beat and and having a
certain sense of like when they
rebranded thor like a lot of that was
like he was really serious up until a
certain point and they're like we need
to have more fun with this character and
i almost feel like hawkeye clint he's
always been a character that has had
some humor and some wit in the mcu but i
feel like this will probably make him
the most lovable that he's been yet also
give us you know a really emotional
passing of that torch and that mantle
and plus you know it looks like this is
gonna have some really awesome action
too not just the bow and arrow stuff the
archery stuff like the car chases look
really great just the potential for
hand-to-hand combat and like set pieces
that are action-packed but more
street-level and the idea that he's
going to have to teach her to be a more
street level hero like all that looks
really
lucid in here and really exciting and
fun it's interesting i bet this will be
a bit more gritty than it looks from
this trailer especially because you got
the christmas music and there's always a
certain like irony and humor that comes
with that it looks like this could be
one of the most fun and exciting just
like
action-oriented shows that they've got
coming you know yeah that's at least
what i'm hoping for is because the last
time we saw clint barton and end game it
was coming off a very gritty portrayal
and then thinking of the matte fraction
run i was sort of imagining that does
have humor like especially the banter
element it's very much present in that
comic that's like what we hone in on
most with the comedy and then you get
the spy qualities to like literally
there was times where i'm like oh this
is a straight up spy movie here
especially when they're like going into
recovery and they have like the bow tie
and everything in the nice dress and
everything like that one he's gonna have
to like juggle spending time away from
the family helping her yeah yeah yeah
like covering up for that haley
steinfeld was like perfectly cast with
this role so
you know they were hearing all these
rumors for the longest time about young
avengers i want them to get west coast
avengers which kate bishop is a part of
like where are all our l.a superheroes
you have a west coast avengers and the
marvel comics do it so let's get the
west coast avengers going guys let's do
it you got your cape bishop established
how many heroes do we need in new york
city man
everyone's saving the big no one's
saving us over here and i'm also hearing
talk that uh kingpin might return here
vincent d'onofrio specifically might be
in here it's just a big rumor valentina
julia louise dreifus character big sense
that she might show up in here and of
course i thought they would show her in
this no yelena biloba in this trailer
you know she's obviously expected to be
in here so that that's credit scene yeah
yeah
maybe i mean she might segue into that
in some way towards the end of the
series but regardless guys what did you
think about the hawkeye trailer are you
excited for it leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that bell hit that
like button last but not least let's do
a
fox if there's anybody who could fill
the shoes of a badass in the mcu like a
hot guy pick up that boner i bet you
already have archery experience you've
already got fight training experience
you inspire me to become a greater
badass in my own life so fox plus you
got the cool ass name you're a perfect
your shoe and you need to be out there
in the streets doing vigilante action
we're counting on you you will be our
west coast avenger fox so make it happen
love you thank you for all your
continued support over at patreon all
your feedback and enthusiasm always
appreciated love you and stay pledged
you